non-minimalists
what are my recycling options if i live
in a city
without a robust recycling program and
some examples here las vegas
where carlos lives missoula where i used
to live missoula montana they had a
terrible recycling program in fact
i wondered if they were just throwing it
away and and calling it recycling it was
a really they didn't recycle glass they
hardly recycled anything and so it was
just difficult i guess the the call
because missoula is so remote
the cost of recycling there it didn't
make sense financially for
a for-profit business and i'm interested
to hear what you have to say
on this because um oh another place i
live phillipsburg montana which is
truly in the middle of nowhere you
basically had to take your own trash to
the trash dump there was no recycling
center anywhere
within a hundred miles of where i was
now that that is a a remote place well
let's take that off the table but for
smaller places or even places like las
vegas that don't have a robust recycling
program
what do you recommend to people well
first of all why doesn't las vegas have
a robust recycling program that's my
question
yes that's what i'd like to know and i
think that that's where my mind goes
is like go to your city council meetings
start talking speak up
that should change right away um las
vegas is not a small town in montana
like you just described so there's
really no reason for that if you ask me
yeah but that's just the way that i
think immediately is that that change
needs to happen and the ball needs to
start rolling right there
yeah first and foremost secondly if
we're talking about plastics
unfortunately to me plastic
recycling is like a big old farce it's
not even happening
um we're at nine percent right now and
some say it's really three percent so
many times kind of stop you there when
you say we're at nine percent
is that nine percent of the say we take
a hundred
plastic bottles and put them in the
recycling only nine of them were being
recycled
correct why is that just because there's
um like you said there's so much first
of all there's a million plastic bottles
being thrown away per minute
in america alone so that is a massive
massive quantity a and b um it's not
like cans and
and gla glassware that actually when you
recycle it it comes out just as good as
new
it degrades so much that it's just not
worth it so
uh many times people feel this like uh
sense of kind of like comfort i'm going
to drink this drink in my plastic water
bottle put it in the recycling bin it'll
get recycled but it's not it's actually
not so
we we really don't believe in recycling
uh plastic at habits of waste we believe
in refusing plastic
all together um we just don't think that
it's even worth
attempting to recycle plastic so it's
not gonna
uh you know you're not gonna make change
unless you just refuse it
and that's not even talking about the
clam shells and cutlery and all that
stuff that's
definitely not going to get recycled
yeah let's talk about that so so with
the straws in particular that that was
the thing that was near and dear to your
heart
obviously it's a piece of plastic you're
not anti-straw you're anti-plastic straw
you can have metal straws and and you're
totally fine with that
um i assume uh but but there are
there are options for us we're allowed
to say no to some of these things and i
think again this is something we don't
think about upfront we're able to say
you know what no i'm not i'm not going
to
accept that i'm going to say no to it
and by the way if the business that
you're
you're buying from refuses you then you
can refuse to do business with them
we get to vote with our with our wallets
that's right and i really think the
mindset shift is right there
it's like instead of thinking of so much
about recycling how can we stop it from
the beginning
how can we just you know turn off the
tap and and
and not even have this problem is is my
goal really
yeah well that actually that dovetails
perfectly into my pithy answer here
the most sustainable purchase is the one
that's left on the shelf
i think quite often we don't think about
that it's like well do i
do i get the this plastic thing or this
plastic thing
which which one's better for the
environment neither yeah right
exactly and what can i do now
of course there are things now you may
have plastic in your home
and it's unfortunate you have a bunch of
plastic maybe you want to get rid of
and it's one of the reasons that i
really dislike places like the container
store
for example because it does two things
really wrong i think uh it's one is
i don't i think organizing is just well
planned hoarding so it doesn't actually
deal with the problem of consumerism and
over-indulgent consumption
but second it creates all this
additional waste plastic
waste as well and so it's this this
i get it i understand the need to want
to be organized
but that's probably not the best route
to take the best way to organize your
stuff
is to is to let go of most of it and the
best way to let go is of course not to
bring it in
in the first place we see these
beautiful pantries on instagram of like
different snacks and this and
it's literally a glorific glorification
of plastic
you know all that packaging all those
plastic bins like let's rewind and just
get back to like the core problem why
are we buying
all those pre-packaged individual snacks
a to put in a plastic container b
you know let's like again let's start
from the beginning can we do things
differently
all together and so so how do we do
things differently what are some of the
old alternatives when
instead of saying well of course it's
gonna be really difficult to get to get
to zero plastic you're not advocating an
all or nothing strategy it's about a
radical reduction in the amount of
plastic we let in but how do we do that
what are the alternatives
buy in bulk number one you know rather
than buying individual packaged bags of
chips for your kids
lunches maybe i understand we're all
human beings we love those goodies
get one big one and then use reusable
containers to divvy it up
you get so much less waste that way
that's just one example another one is
it's really fun to try and make recipes
like your own granola your own
bars your own fruit leathers there's a
lot of
opportunities right now especially since
many people are still at home
to create uh recipes that are just fun
to do with your kids and you just
create them with so much less waste yeah
yeah
i'm thinking about our home and we we
have some you know glass containers
reusable i think the key to the
reusables is actually reusing
them because sometimes good intentions
are i'm going to buy these reusable
things
but it's actually worse for the
environment if you buy something and
then you just
don't reuse it you end up throwing it
away or discarding it relatively quickly
can you talk about that some jars like
you said i buy like pickle jars or some
different pickles or
whatever it is like a glass jar and
those are my to-go containers so i leave
them in my car if i'm going to a
restaurant and i'll take them in and
i'll refill them with the food that i
would have
otherwise asked for a to-go box and it's
going to be either polystyrene or
plastic or even aluminum with a plastic
lid or if i have leftovers at home and i
want to pass it out to like friends and
family i fill those up
and i pass it out like that and they can
continue living just
you know constantly i might make a green
juice at home and fill those jars up
with with the juice
so it it is so beautiful to go and buy
these amazing bottles and this and that
you don't really need to your my water
bottle is a tomato
sauce jar actually and it's a beautiful
bottle
it's a company called muti and i tagged
them and i was like you know these can
be really great water bottles afterwards
so they start reposting and
you know who said a water bottle needs
to be branded to you as a water bottle
yeah by the way just thinking about that
term branding you know
it's i think of branding as a pejorative
i don't want to wear a bunch of logos on
my clothes it's free average
i paid someone for the privilege of
advertising on my body or aren't we
doing the same thing with these fancy
sports bottles or whatever
and in a weird way we're trying to
indicate something about
ourselves who we are as a person through
this this brand but of course
i think we can never accomplish that i
think the last thing i want to
to touch on with carlos's question here
is i think
it it may even seem overly simplistic to
say
but the less we consume the less waste
we
produce and and i want to think about
that because as a minimalist the
environmentalism was not
a the the primary objective for me when
we first started simplifying
but it was this beautiful byproduct of
consuming
less stuff there was less packaging less
waste less things to donate or throw
away or try to sell
it it was and it was maybe
the the best unintended benefit of of
living with less
you